2 herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
läuten wir sind im urlaub wir vielleicht
einen geänderten hintergrund erkennt
aber trotzdem mache ich ein video that
can be kannten so etwas nichts vermisse
und zwar haben wir folgendes wir machen
so eine ganze wird challenge roth darum
geht dazu einfach die lippen leben muss
und mir so ich sag kein wort sebastian
dabei kopfhörer auf die nach möglichkeit
gar nichts davon herzlich danke und er
muss nur an meinen lippen ablesen was
ich für ein wort gesagt habe dass
steigern wir die von einem wort sagt
vielleicht und vielleicht irgendwie mal
fremdwörter irgendwie komplizierte folgt
ich habe heute richtig schwierig weil
man nicht verbieten kann ich gar nicht
mit anfang so lamy ja oder nein aktuell
ableben aber alles was darüber liegt ist
nicht schwer
die reaktion auf den kopf gewachsen
packt die kopfhörer rein ich überlege
schon mein erstes wort das wieder
benutzt musikhören künstler anwesen
künstler wie kino wartet also hält eine
million followers werke heute maximale
lautstärke
also ich höre die musik ist ein
hässlicher und womöglich wirklich stimmt
es okay gut funktioniert erklärt ok und
so darf ihren riesen armin von der
aktiven ihre jacke miteinander geht zum
leicht und sozial schwarzer dem scheiß
einfach mal ipod iphone iphone
iphone apps musik ausgemacht iphone
aber gerade als man erwarten video
antwort a ja vielleicht ein computer
solche eine million or 1 3651 verstanden
also gehört hast du gar nicht dass
irgendwer vielleicht wieder klappen wir
nehmen weil ich bin und warum
da freue ich nehme das längst proteine
gesehen vielleicht wieder zulegen werden
vereinbart seien aber zwei dinge
verstanden
produzent produzent ist nicht ganz wohl
eine art gehört der kamera richtige
wortwahl proteine aber dann lange
feststecken
egal ob irgendwas verstehe nicht so laut
reden machen
die flasche war klasse
ich verstehe wirklich nicht wieder so
wenn es im gespräch rede wie das ipad
wir machen einen kurzen satz machen was
auf der hand liegt eigentlich muss man
hören und zu wissen dass max ist geil
ist geil
[Musik]
eine ahnung gehabt den letzten
entwicklungen liegt aber korrekt war
also ist geil stimmt aber es war
natürlich macht aber dafür kenne ich auf
jeden fall drei folgt oder du kannst dir
immer als durch die musik durch das
folge meinen musikgeschmack und
vielleicht würde ich dachte meine haare
machen wir mein englisch ist
wahrscheinlich gerade laut duh
ich habe eine million
da sitzt jemand verdächtige als mit
mimik und gestik ja und aber als ich auf
eine million mitleser englischen lord
packt sie auf die ohren bei fragen ist
auf jeden fall nur einen grundwert mega
vertrag jetzt erstes englisches wort
nehmen will ganz einfach über lockerbie
von upgrade ist bei uns ja ich würde
sagen dass ich glaube das war einfach
nur daran dass die studierenden anderer
bischof hat und besser hören konnte ich
hab kein wort klinik sollte prämiert und
wiederbelebt werden sagt er wird schon
bewusstlos als hauptstrafe durch die
macht macht hallo leute wir machen einen
blog
also ich zeige euch liebe gott ich muss
aufstieg
dankenswerter weise sagen und sagt jetzt
das erste mal gefrühstückt zb auch den
mittlerweile war wieder da so lasse
jetzt gehen wir feiern da für mich
leider nicht mehr hat da habe ich in den
klub nicht rausschmeißen
ich bin richtig sehr guter tag war so
lang
jetzt kann ich endlich schlafen sie wird
dann wurde ich hoffe euch auf der
blockfreien last leichter